one of the advisors to data in society
has appeared on numerous podcasts and
praised
uh the former web dev from the daily
stormer
she was heavily criticized for this has
tried coming out and making like you
know oh no no it's just my research but
there's a podcast from i believe it may
be from wnyc where she's talking about
oh this neo-nazi guy it's all just jokes
it's all just lolol the big swastika on
his chest and all these things it's just
funny haha and that's that's one of
their advisors so if they want if they
want to lay accusations towards me
because i i kid you not one of their
accusations was that in a video someone
walked past me
i was at a party at vidcon where there's
thousands of people i've never met i
showed up to do an interview with a guy
and as as someone's interviewing talking
to me on their camera someone was like
walked in after the fact and she says
that connects them it's like okay i
never had a word to that person i've
never met them i just saw them at a
party when you shake hands your
organization has an advisor who has
appeared on shows
and praised an actual neo-nazi
the basic quest for truth let's say that
some people are on
versus just the rest of this crew that
wants to just watch scorched earth or
just destroy everything that that really
is what the culture war is about because
you and i have pretty significant
political differences and it is
and i know and correct me for wrong it's
it's irrelevant to me i think it's
irrelevant to you you know we can we can
do those discussions and we've done them
before yeah i don't think we have to do
them now because there's so many other
things to talk about but it's like i
think we both know that we're on
basically the same quest for something
that's true right right decent that we
want people to live free but but that's
what the culture war really is about
it's that you've got this little sliver
of people trying really trying and we're
dealing with people that basically act
like like heath ledger's joker i think i
think wanted to burn but i think there
are sociopaths left and the rights got
them there are people that i believe on
the left and the right who are grifters
i don't know which side has more or less
um i don't publicly call people as
grifters because i i can never prove
even to myself i'm like i think
something about that person i don't
trust them but that would that would be
really unfair to accuse them of being
disingenuous on things that they're
truly passionate about
but i think what we have kind of in the
culture war is
you know i saw something on twitter
where there's this activist who works
for nbc and he's literally an activist
he's lobbied twitter for action so i
can't call him a journalist and he was
claiming that everyone who criticized
captain marvel or brie larson was an
insult
and i said
did a piece on it today and i'm like
you can't clearly think that every
single person is not getting laid that's
a really you're very clearly trying to
trigger and attack people but the
important point was that for the record
i'm getting late and i have no desire to
see it well yeah but so uh the point you
know i i tried bringing up just calmly
to one uh it was a buzzfeed reporter who
quoted it i didn't argue four against i
said here's what people are thinking and
his response was that i was engaged in
far-right propaganda and i've lost my
mind and i'm like
he was like i don't see any of these
conversations on reddit therefore it's
far-right propaganda youtube is
dominated by far-right propaganda and
i'm like
i realized something because someone
commented this reddit is moderated
particularly by the companies you know
they want to make sure they're promoting
their content and there's very few
things that can appear but youtube is a
very libertarian platform where whatever
works works it's very
meritocratic so on youtube if your video
is good and entertaining people watch it
what does that mean well they're not in
cells it means that a lot of people are
watching these videos and youtube is
saying if people like it we're going to
show it that's not a rabbit hole of
conspiracy theories it's a lot of these
videos
uh criticizing captain marvel very
simply people saying i'm sure the movie
will do well i'm sure it's gonna be like
a moderately good marvel film i just
don't like brie larson because she's
very snooty and condescending i'm gonna
sit this one out yeah there are some
people that's completely how i feel i
love all the marvel movies i love them
event uh infinity war was i think the
best one that was great yeah i'm so
excited for the best one i can't wait
for the next one and i have no desire to
see it because i saw her little speech
and it's like you know what i just don't
want to support you we if we keep
supporting these people who are so
contrary to at least the things that i
believe in it's like the only way you
can ever get change because i don't want
the government to stop them i want i
want them to stop themselves but so so
here's the thing i don't i don't feel
that way for me it's kind of that uh
they marketed the movie as a big
feminist film brie larson's own words
the commercial has a big her in the
screen and then a and o appears so it
says a hero and i'm like i see where
they're going with this i sat through
ghostbusters i sat to the last jedi i'm
gonna sit this one out until the reviews
come in i got no beef with marvel or
brie larson i don't like the things she
says but chris evans captain america
says crazy
things too oh mark ruffalo makes it
right right right so i can separate the
art from the artist but when your
marketing is overwhelmingly reminiscent
of ghostbusters in last jedi i'm gonna
i'm gonna wait yeah and i'm hearing it's
boring um you know it's got like a 6.6
on metacritic and even left-wing outlets
are saying it's mediocre and boring at
best so i'm like maybe i won't see it
yeah well it definitely was the nazi
trolls that have screwed up and that's
the crazy thing about the ratings
they're already they're already seeding
that out there there's an outlet that
wrote a story saying uh trolls are uh
right right-wing trolls are preparing a
campaign to destroy the ratings and
their their uh story was we saw one
person on twitter who said let's do this
and i was like yeah how many he had
apparently had no followers i'm like
random twitter account did you make it
like who cares what
but that's why this is this also is so
strange to me because we can see these
trends all over the place so remember
when there was that video of
ocasio-cortez dancing nobody cared and
then nobody cared i complimented her i
saw all all the conservatives were all
of them all the verified conservatives
that of any following of note were like
oh this is kind of cute or i don't like
her but she's a human bubba and then but
all this all the uh the main media
conservatives going crazy and most of
them they didn't link to anything or
they would link to an anonymous account
that you don't even know it was one
account yeah that sounds like this
was that newsweek which one it was it
was anonymous uh no i know but what what
what uh outlet wrote
that article oh i don't know but they
were i was everyone your times wrote
about it yeah when i first saw that
video i left and i said i tweeted
something like wow this makes her seem
really relatable and endearing it's
really it's uh i said it makes her look
like she's fun and i come like it was
like a compliment i'm like i'm like wow
that's that's really cool that we have
this video of like a college fun time
they were recreating breakfast club
dances i mean i don't i i know that
those people will lump me in with
conservatives i don't think of me that
way but
the first response i saw from literally
everybody was like lol this is so funny
like it's fun
but then when you see that at the
political level and we see it all the
time at sort of the gamer level or the
twitter level or whatever you realize
that these these themes like it doesn't
take a genius to put some of this
together but all right let's let's shift
a little bit so first off we're gonna do
we'll do like an hour of q a from the
audience yeah yeah you down for that
whatever so we're gonna do that but i
want to do a bunch more here first but
people can submit on on the super chat
right now let's talk about uh my
favorite organization in america even
more i like these guys even more than
the southern poverty hate center
data in society oh the conspiracy theory
tell me a little bit about data and
society they put up a chart the
alternative influencer well they're
directly associated with
they're directly connected to the daily
stormer yeah that's a fact and i i i've
mentioned this in the past and people on
the left had the same reaction that we
have to their conspiracy theory crime
web and
actually the connection between date and
society to neo-nazism is extremely
direct relative to what they claimed so
one of their advisors has
explained what data society is yeah so
data society is it's a new york-based
think tank of progressives that are
tracking data social media and how it
impacts society and they do a lot of
research looking into far-right and
russian interference one of the people
so
this is great i hope i hope they're
listening i i have an insider who's been
feeding me information and i know
they're working on like a russian
document right now and the woman who's
writing it tweets every three minutes
about some nonsensical conspiracy theory
and i laughed i'm like it represents
them very well but i hope they're
listening and they know that
somebody inside their organization has
sent me like so i also know that they've
admitted the connections in their report
the alternative influence network their
direct quote sent to me was some of
these are not factual
so i have you know
and that's and that's how they admitted
to you that the report was debunked
there were errors related to me i mean
basically it's just a bunch of names
i'll say this i have been fed insider
information and one of the statements
given to me
by an individual not from them yeah but
through someone associated in a certain
capacity i'm trying to be uh very
careful not to expose yeah uh was
uh a quote
some of these are not factual and
there's there's more there um but that
was that was a you know yeah so
ultimately i just you know whatever
right but what's interesting about it is
it's not just whatever because we then
see how these studies that we're based
in nothing other than oh this person
appeared with this person or this person
did a live stream with this person and
then you link it together and it looks
like some sort of massive network of
crazy people scheming together and the
connections are fake some of them the
connections were often fake but not only
that there was no evidence that the
whole premise of it this alternative
influence network was that this group of
people that included sam harris and
jordan peterson and you and me and a
whole bunch of others that we've
radicalized people to the far right when
in fact there is actual data right that
has shown that i've actually
re de-radicalized people of the right
and made them more liberal in a lot of
cases and i've actually not that
antidote evidence is is enough in and of
itself but i have a lot of evidence for
that more importantly it claims that
youtube channels
okay sam harris does he have a youtube
channel he does um but they also
mentioned james damore who
at least at the time didn't know there
was there was four people listed that
weren't youtubers some that were on
youtube with like a thousand subscribers
that posted one or two videos at some
point and i'm like
that's a fake that's fake narrative but
let's i want to make something
absolutely clear that thing that i had
muted on twitter because i can't yeah
yeah because they're going after me and
the the report is implying that we're
like you know oh yeah and and they try
to get into they they try to dance
around the nuance of understanding that
uh one of the problems was they said
these people hold views from libertarian
to uh from mainstream conservative
libertarian to white nationalists i
don't fit that bracket at all absolutely
not yeah uh simply because i define
you're not a white nationalist oh yeah
my my my mixed race family would fit
really really well into a note
completely oh it's half korean quarter
crane actually quarter yeah yeah i have
halfway so
so so here's the important thing
one of the advisors who did in society
has appeared on numerous podcasts and
praised uh the former web dev from the
daily stormer
she was heavily criticized for this has
tried coming out and making like you
know oh no no it's just my research but
there's a podcast from i believe it may
be from wnyc where she's talking about
oh this neo-nazi guy it's all just jokes
it's all just lolol the big swastika on
his chest and all these things it's just
funny haha and that's that's one of
their advisors so if they want if they
want to lay accusations towards me
because i i kid you not one of their
accusations was that in a video someone
walked past me i was at a party at
vidcon where there's thousands of people
i've never met i showed up to do an
interview with a guy and as as someone's
interviewing talking to me on their
camera someone was like walked in after
the fact and she says that connects them
it's like okay i never had a word to
that person i've never met them i just
saw them at a party when you shake hands
your organization has an advisor who has
appeared on shows and praised an actual
neo-nazi
well depending on who you ask they'll
say he's not really a neo-nazi i don't
want to drag people by naming them but
it's an individual who's one of the most
notorious trolls on the planet was
associated with the daily stormer has a
swastika on their chest i'll leave it
there
and
i will point out too
people who who know uh the woman and
this man will say it's unfair to
characterize them in that manner but if
we're going by the standard set by data
and society right there you literally
have
a woman who's written a book
and defended
to the extent where she said it's just a
joke it's just a game it's it's it's
funny
well tell that to them they should tell
that to themselves if they think it's
funny to get a tattoo of a swastika on
your chest and to to make horrifying
jokes about marginalized communities
that's their standard for what's funny
or at least one of their advisors i have
to question their motives when they want
to accuse me of being a gateway to
anything maybe you should look
internally you know clean your house
clean your room before trying to change
the world right it's right over there
exactly in a weird way is it a sort of
depressing reality like when i've
watched some of your videos and and you
get engineers at these companies and
we're gonna we're gonna talk about all
of them uh to admit things that we all
are sort of thinking or true related to
shadow banning or de-boosting or
everything else there's a piece of me
even when they're they're tipping off
the information that i suspect is true
there's a piece of me that's like ah
this is this is so there's something
sort of depressing about this that this
is what we've been left with like we
have to go after you know mid-level and
sometimes low-level engineers and
sometimes the bigger ones but because
there's no transparency when it comes to
these companies so it feels almost
depressing to me does that does that
well i think the way that i would put it
like it's unfortunate i suppose
some people call it depressing some
people say we confirm suspicions i would
say that what we do is summon
righteous indignation
at the tragedies in society including in
these organizations
because they run so counter to what were
spoon-fed the narratives that were spoon
fed by the media by the powers that be
so hidden camera journal investigative
reporting whether it's hidden camera or
print does that it it summons what ida
tarbell termed as righteous indignation
at the tragedies and a kind of you know
most people i would say 80
there's a sort of consensus around what
we do people say well that's wrong or
they deny it so twitter
the twitter lobbyist in congress under
oath said we do not shadowband when his
engineer
clearly said what we do do is shadow ban
and we i don't know if we do that
anymore that's what the engineer said
clearly meaning that he had shadow
banned people so
um it's it's perjury to lie under oath
and and you know these hidden camera
videos really show people what's going
on it angers people i think the world is
more polarized than it was 10 years ago
so maybe that 80 percent consensus is is
is going down yeah are you worried at
all though that we'll always be
videotaping each other and that there
will be nothing that's private i mean
even now if i go out to dinner like i'm
aware that i'm some level of a public
person and sometimes people recognize me
and sometimes i was at the airport and
it was very obvious to me that the guy i
was sitting with somebody but the guy
next to me clearly knew who i was and he
was on this computer and the whole time
i'm thinking this guy could be recording
me you know and and just all like just
this endless big brother thing even if
the intentions of what you're doing i do
believe to be good are you just worried
about just that general state of we're
all going to be recording each other all
the time there will be nothing private
i'm not worried at all i mean there's an
element of risk every time you interact
with strangers and you talk to them as
long as there's one party present to the
conversation we would argue that it's
ethical and again we think that
cameras visuals are merely an extension
i mean i could i could disseminate what
you tell me in private i could write it
down and shout it from the rooftops
upton sinclair when he wrote the jungle
he saw everything and then he ran back
to his hotel and wrote it all down so
surely society would would rather a
situation where i accurately capture
what it is that you told me and i have
to use cameras they indemnify me because
people call me a liar they say that
didn't happen
so i have to i have to record the
incidents because they would they would
say that it did not happen the way that
i reported it
i also think that i think that there are
lines that we can't cross we don't go
into people's bedrooms we try to stay
away from the really personal intimate
you know sexual details about about
people but this is a revolution that's
aimed at the power structure at this
establishment the powers that be not
against
private citizens and we don't i think
there is a duty there is a
responsibility that investigative
reporters have not to put people on
blast unless it really meets a
compelling public interest
so you mentioned you started this in in
college what was tipping you off to like
that there was something wrong with the
media i mean what made you go i got to
go in there and say i'm irish and i'm
offended by lucky charms like what
really was happening that you were
seeing that led to that well i was in at
rutgers university in new jersey and it
was so the political correctness was run
amok like most schools don't tell me
there's something bad happening with the
grease trucks please the grease trucks
you know i know the grease trucks please
tell me that they're okay
for those who don't know there's these
trucks at rutgers and it's like they're
all in a parking lot and uh and you get
real fat real quick only a cop there was
something you know what there was
something wrong with the groceries they
had duct they put duct tape this is in
2005 over these sandwiches am i allowed
to curse on them
there was one of them called the fat the
fat [ __ ] and the fat uh
dyke and other words that were offensive
and um they had put duct tape over the
names because these words were
considered offensive that's what was the
what compelled me to try to ban lucky
charms
so i said this is ridiculous i also had
professors who were stalinists i had
professors who were telling me how great
communist communism was and i
was not political but i read the new
york times every day front to back in
college in the dining hall i was sort of
an introverted guy and i'd read the
paper and i was just i said this doesn't
accurately capture the world this
doesn't
this doesn't tell people what's really
going on so i i felt compelled to to do
something about it and it wasn't
comfortable it's not comfortable to
confront people with cameras and you
know get into their faces but i was
willed to do it because i believed in
the cause and and the the kind of
valinsky uh methodology which is to make
them accountable to their own principles
you know you had these marxist
professors driving bentleys and bmws and
had a little muckraking newspaper and it
was like lifestyles of the rich and
marxist right
right you know track these people down i
i just feel that most people that do
this most insiders inside these
companies coming to us
now have what i call a justice complex
they think that there are things wrong
with the world and they feel compelled
to do something about it's hard to
explain
but you know i'm sure you know people
who have this complex and these people
are willing to basically jump on a
grenade
to wear a camera to film their employer
some cases violating their own
non-disclosure agreement because they
believe the public has a right to know
what they're seeing are you shocked at
the amount of people at these big tech
companies who now are willing to speak
because i mean i know insiders that i
get some information from i mean i'm
talking about google facebook twitter
like that really these things have
become so huge
that now their own people inside them
are going whoa what what did we help
create here i'm not you've got a
monster i mean i i have you been to
menlo park and and you go to san
francisco and i i was there because i
did this facebook story this insider
inside facebook and i went to try to
locate these engineers and ask them for
comment and there were just these buses
just hundreds of buses
filled with millennials and and if you
go to the campus people are sort of
driving around these bicycles the best
word i can describe it is their minions
it's just sort of this little
totalitarian little mini state within a
state and it's just a group think
orwellian place
and i and i guess the the word that it
was described to me by the inside is
that they're all minions they're very
intelligent people but they don't have a
lot of common sense and they're
and i and i went there i was amazed by
this menlo park campus buses of of young
people being
bussed in and i think that it doesn't
surprise me that people are willing to
blow the whistle because there's more to
life than than making you know a quarter
million dollars a year and working for
these companies people want to people
want to do something one of the things
that i get told all the time what can i
do
and and there aren't a lot of choices
for people you know you can you can
watch the shows you can buy the books
but some people want to actually
participate in this country and and
solutions are increasingly you know
outside the scope of government the
legislative process does not seem to
solve things so there's there needs to
be an a different counterweight there
needs to be a different solution
and i would say that point
zero
zero one percent of people are like put
a camera on me that's a lot of people by
the way yeah right right right we're
talking about a lot of people at the end
of the day one of the things that i'm
realizing now that i'm back on the grid
is i spend so much of the time on my
show just cleaning up lies
just aoc said this it's a lie cnn said
this it's alive kavanaugh everything
they said was a lie covington kids all
the stuff that you've covered obviously
and i'm just a little curious uh first
off like how bad you think really like
the cnn msnbc new york times wapo
machine is on one hand but on the other
hand just like a little insider stuff on
how you guys go about doing your show on
a daily basis because i know your
producers a little bit and obviously i
go on the show and i find that you do
the show in a way where it's like you're
almost doing like uh it almost feels
more like a book than a tv show where
it's like each day you're doing
something and then you sort of pick up
the next day and pick up the next day
and i'm trying to do something similar
here so that everything doesn't feel
like this disconnected lunacy that that
everyone else in i'm just wondering a
little bit about like the nuts and bolts
about how you guys decide to do what
you're gonna do
well i'm a writer so that's that's how i
think you know in terms of chapters and
you know serials this is a story you
know i'm giving you one installment
today another tomorrow it's just how my
brain works
um but it's a practical matter you know
i wake up not too early i hope
and uh with my wife and four dogs i try
and sit outside for a minute get my head
together and then i write out a memo
every morning for the whole staff on
what i think the lead ought to be who we
should book and we've got a whole
pipeline of some unbelievable people who
work
on the show just really really smart i
mean really smart and um
one of the people i talk to a lot so you
know we've had if i can brag the same
staff for five years i think we've lost
one person two people it's pretty big
staff um
and they're just they're all in they're
so clever they're so creative they're so
interesting but one of our our head tape
guy is a guy called tom fox a guy's
freaking genius
and he really is my window into cable
news like
the poor guy he's very smart but he
watches all his cables
so he's constantly texting he drinks a
lot i'm guessing
what he drinks a lot i'm guessing i i
don't he seems pretty sober but i mean
maybe he's on pills i don't know
but i like you know i sit there with my
you know stupid glasses on and my phone
and i'm looking up i honestly can't
believe that i cannot believe they
didn't say this
um so basically by like 11 30 in the
morning you know i've sketched out what
i think the show should be in my mind
it's always because again i was a
reporter and a magazine writer i think
in terms of the lead you know what's
my editor used to say to me when i was
kid get in the lead like but what's the
lead like how do you open it up
you know what's the what's the theme
and i try to
as just a as an exercise that i've
always
um
you know that i learned as a kid and
i've always used sum it up in a sentence
you know what's it about you know our
first segment usually goes 20 25 minutes
what's it about one sentence it's not
about eight things it's about one thing
how would you summarize it and that's a
really
helpful organizing principle
for putting it together
and then you know right around five
o'clock i try and take a sauna every day
because i think it's really important
it's scandinavian i'm true to my people
and uh i think about it in the sauna
then i go out i think about it more and
then i sit down around five have a cup
of coffee and i start writing
um the lead and so that's basically it
but
the media stuff is so shocking to me
because i you know i worked at cnn for
years and i posted a couple shows there
several shows there and then i you know
i was the main anchor on msnbc for four
years i got fired
but you know i i still have a really
good friend who will remain nameless who
works there just a wonderful person
really good guy and i have a couple of
friends at cnn so
not a ton too
but uh but anyway but i know that world
really really well
and the biggest surprise for me in one
sentence is how ill liberal they are i
always imagine they're liberal networks
no no i'm liberal okay in the sense that
like i believe in the enlightenment and
i i believe in the bill of rights and i
think we do have rights
um
they are not liberals they are defenders
of the powerful which is the much graver
sin like you can have silly politics i
get it i've had silly politics maybe i
do now people make mistakes
but defending the billionaire class
blaming everything on like working-class
white people who are like you know
by far
the most shafted people in america look
at the suicide rate look at the death
rate i mean it's like it's measurable
but everything's their fault
it's insane cnn ran a piece today saying
white supremacists are applauding the
taliban and it's like okay uh you know i
don't even know what they're talking
about
but but leaving that aside it's like
what are you really saying you're saying
the real problem with the withdrawal
from afghanistan was not terrible
decisions that the body administration
made of the pentagon made or that our
entire foreign policy establishment
bipartisan made for 20 years now the
real problem is some guy in alabama
who's got unauthorized views it's like
maybe you should stop attacking these
people because they are the weakest
people in our society and you're doing
it
in order to defend like the shittiest
people in our society but also the
richest and the most powerful you're the
praetorian guard for the most powerful
people like how can you live with
yourself i mean that that is so immoral
what do you think what do you think the
answer to that question is how do they
when when you have to cover some idiotic
thing that stelter said or cuomo
just these these clown people when you
have to cover it right or don lemon as
you call them like what how do you think
they live with themselves at this point
when they just lie again and again and
we have the internet to expose the lies
if this isn't 20 years ago when you were
on cnn yeah and we couldn't expose
things we can expose it now and they
still do it
well it's i guess i would ask myself
like i mean i lie
if i'm really cornered or something i
lie
i really try not to
i try never to lie on tv i just don't
you know i don't like lying i certainly
do it you know out of weakness or
whatever but to systematically lie like
that
without
asking yourself like why am i doing this
so if if these people ask themselves why
am i doing this you say well because i
want to protect
the system because i really believe in
the system okay who's running the system
you're you're lying to defend jeff bezos
like you're treating
you're treating bill gates like some
sort of moral leader like are you
kidding like how dare you do that how
dare you use your power
to protect and guard the powerful
even as you
clamped you know put your boot on the
neck of the weakest piece some some
catholic school kid from kentucky it's
like a parody are you kidding he's a
child
and you're using your power to
to crush him to wreck his life like that
that shocks me and i have to say there
have been many times in the 25 years
i've been in tv where i think
you know are we using this
like very substantial power that we have
to put pictures on the screen
to hurt
weak people
and i have done that inadvertently over
the years because i got carried away but
i really try not to and everyone who
works on our show
is very aware of like the most
basic rule which is don't piss down
don't attack people beneath you if
you're gonna you know take a punch make
sure it's upward someone who's rich or
stronger more powerful in charge of more
things than you are punch up
like that's just like a life rule and
people who punch down are the are the
worst they should have no power
whatsoever in my opinion well what do
you think about the the big tech element
then also that you know going forward
that
at least
even though they did nothing i mean i
kept saying this the whole time you guys
are having these hearings and it's great
to see ted cruz who i totally like and
respect it's great to see him grill jack
but you guys are doing it six days
before an election and we're pretending
that this is in theater
are you worried that okay trump was sort
of the last thing that was stopping big
tech from doing whatever it might want
to do i i don't know what exactly what
it wants to do but now without that
threat of we're going to regulate you
whatever it might you know break you up
stuff that i don't particularly want
them to do
are you worried that they're just gonna
go all in and and silence the real
resistance which will be
you know the remaining free thinkers yes
i am worried about that i i don't have
the solution to that either i i am
worried
i think
one of the sad things but the realities
over the past 20 25 years is the
republicans have shown themselves to be
very good at winning elections
maybe not in this particular case for
the white house but in general they win
elections and very bad at fighting the
culture wars and
it's unfortunate because now the
democrats control the media
hollywood
academia big tech
and
half the country doesn't feel
represented at all in
almost all of the information that comes
back to them publicly like sports forgot
to mention them so you turn on the
television and watch a sports game or
get the news or watch the oscars or the
vmas whatever it is
and
now you're getting woke ism shoved down
your neck and you're being told you're a
racist if you happen to be a republican
you like trump or even just if you're a
republican these days
and
you send it a tweet that is totally
legitimate and maybe just opinionated or
a news story being reported by that new
york post
censored censored censored you know your
viewpoints are you're being told they're
bad by everyone that has control of the
public microphones and i do think it
leads people to be like
am i insane am is everything i think
i
it's a problem
i think big tech is part of the problem
i really wish we would see somebody like
peter thiel you know who you know
he's going to have to actively create a
new twitter and a new facebook and like
there needs to be a real
other digital forum out there that
represents the other half of the country
because i just don't think they've got
much of a future on the existing
platforms well the irony is if trump
loses and then it finally gives him the
impetus to be like okay i'm going to
another platform or i'm starting my own
platform that's how the platform will
will work right like that ultimately
would be it no you don't you don't think
that would be enough no i think that'll
be like i mean with all due respect sean
hannity starting his own network like
you know you know what you're gonna get
you're not gonna get real analysis that
now that's no no i don't mean i don't
mean you'll get analysis i mean if trump
is just like all right i'm going i'm
going to parlor or i'm going to locals
or wherever that it would be like
everyone would go there just because
he's still the show in a way oh no
questions yeah i don't mean that he's
going to create some non-partisan
network or something
conservative media is well represented
in the digital world i get that but when
it comes to these main the main
platforms out there i mean facebook is
it gives a little bit more play but
they're they're censoring a lot of stuff
too but if you could have a real and i
know there's parlor i'm on parlor but
it's just it's not what twitter is and
i don't know that it's going to be you
need a real player with a lot of money
to to create the platform and back it
and somebody with a spine of steel like
rupert murdoch to say
i don't need to be loved at the cocktail
parties i'm gonna let this be a real
forum for
mainstream conservative thought in other
words we don't need alex jones on there
okay but like dave rubin does not need
to get censored right and
i i that's my only thought because i
you're not going to change jack dorsey
you're not going to change facebook
you're not going to change these big
tech organizations for whom it's like
deeply ideological
they think it's the difference between
good and evil you know it's not just
about getting biden elected it's about
silencing the rest of these racists did
you see that clip from sunny hostin on
the view yeah
unbelievable
that
that embodies how they think the the
left wing and i don't even mean
progressives i know you used to be one
most professors i know are totally
normal and mainstream and they don't
believe in any of this nonsense it's the
quote left with the capital l who are
insane in the way they see the other
half of the country and sunny hosting
just put it on display where it was like
these at least half the country i'm not
going to say they're racists yeah
whatever is
they'll see the races but at least half
the country
voted for him notwithstanding his racism
his sex sympathism his xenophobia his
transphobia
and
then another woman on the panel sarah i
don't remember her name but she was like
how can you say that you know people
vote in their own self-interest all the
time pocket book issues and so on
doesn't make them bad doesn't make them
racist and the response was
no because this is about we the people
and we are supposed to behave as a
collective and do what is right it's one
of those things dave i was like oh my
god i wish so badly for the first time
in my life that i was sitting on the
view
i would have loved to said to her i i
get it totally
and just out of curiosity i'm wondering
because like there's a lot of people who
really feel like for example um
abortion is murder and it's actually
killing babies and that's wrong and what
would be right would be to ban it
outright and if you don't support that
you are on the wrong side you're in
favor of murder and and we the people
responds you to behave as a collective
right like i could go on for you know
give me five other examples like the
outrage and by the way let's look at the
southern border you know the people down
there who have had family members killed
by people illegally coming across with
drugs and weapons
who have lost jobs to people who are
here unlawfully in the country they have
real reasons for wanting a great border
wall and for cracking down on illegal
immigration and if you don't support it
you're the one who doesn't care about
life and the well-being of your fellow
citizens and we the people
who died and made her
king of we the people right it's like do
you think that's how they think
do you think they'll ever stop that
thing like that in many ways what you
just described there that is the thing
that most
the rest of us are fighting we don't
have to make it about sunny but that
thing and it's been so successful and
and as we're talking potentially is
about to dethrone donald trump why would
they stop doing it
they're not going to
they're not going to and i i agreed with
the headlines this week that said wokism
was dealt a blow during this election
because he saw you know his numbers as
you pointed out with all these minority
groups go up people the minority groups
like him more than they used to not less
like four years of ubiquitous media
coverage telling them he's awful racist
bigot all the stuff and that they're
awful if they like it
so that didn't work oh and by the way i
mean even just today there was a
congressman a democratic congresswoman
who was saying
uh defund the police killed us
killed us that is why we went down in
the house instead of up and if we don't
abandon that ridiculous messaging we're
going to see a bloodbath in two years so
wokism
you know the messaging was proven to be
a failure when it comes to electoral
politics but that won't deter them
that's not going to stop anything
but for the reasons i was saying
it's ideological it makes them feel like
better people superior
i don't know if it's their guilt
if it's just the virtue signaling makes
them feel great about themselves in bed
at night when they judge other people
and decide they're all bad
so we're gonna have to deal with it and
the people who don't believe in this
bs culture and there's so many people in
the center right who don't either look
at the harpers leather letter look at
people like andrew sullivan who hated
trump but you know he's completely
taking a stand against this baloney
they're going to have to speak up
the people who are against it i know
they're afraid
i know you can get fired now for the
most ridiculous reasons trust me i know
um
we're going to have to start taking
risks otherwise we're all going to go
down we're going to go down together on
this war i i spent more of my time i
think talking about the press and the
mainstream media more than i do about
politics specifically i actually find
that far more interesting it's like
politics sort of is what it is but it's
the filter that's more interesting to me
that because that's what shapes how we
all act and behave and think about all
of it
yeah it fascinates me i think you know
one of
i guess my um
deep deep frustrations is the fact you
know i brought accountability from the
podium i obviously had a massive
platform to do it you know cnn msnbc had
to report on the things i was saying
even if they contorted it um but now you
know being in the private sector uh the
megaphone's less and it's easy to you
don't have a republican press secretary
to let go all of these stories that have
been proven false that day in and day
out i told the press so i was blue in
the face no
trump there were not russian bounties on
the heads of troops in afghanistan that
trump ignored no he did not gas and
pummel protesters to take a photo shoot
at the church these things have now been
proven false but there's just virtually
no reporting there's no megaphone like
the white house uh podium to shout that
these narratives are false but i think
the best thing viewers can do is share
with your friends hey no that lafayette
square thing yeah that didn't happen it
wasn't as reported the inspector general
found otherwise the covet lavley theory
trump was so crazy to proffer in fact
now looks to be true so or at least
plausible so you know i think we've got
to have accountability even in the
aftermath and that means all of us using
our tiny megaphones to create a very big
one did any of the lies get to trump i
mean the the very fine people one to me
that's what joe biden used in his
campaign launch video that trump
defended the neo-nazis and it's like no
he literally said i am condemning the
white supremacist and the neo-nazis when
he said find people he meant fine people
on the both sides of the debate about
statues generally speaking did any of
that get to him or he was just like
that's that's what it is
yeah i think you know he's so used to at
this point you know four years and he
was so used to the tired old false
defamatory labels if you're a racist
you're a bigot all of this like he was
used to those narratives i think the
only time that i really saw something
get to him and i'm sure that got to him
in the raw heat of the moment you know
years prior before i came uh but the one
thing that i saw really get to him uh
was when there was the reporting from
the atlantic that trump had called
our fallen heroes our fallen military
men and women suckers and losers it's
the one time i saw a negative story just
um become an obsession of his because it
was just so not true so deeply hurtful
he kept saying over and over again what
kind of monster would do that we had two
dozen sources on the record with their
names on it saying this was not true um
but they ran with the egregious lie
because they were trying to leave away
the military base that is strongly
supportive of trump away from him so you
know his taxes that rolled off of his
shoulder he didn't care the new york
times hit pieces about his taxes but he
did deeply care about that
in in retrospect now that he's not
president do you guys think that uh
there were mistakes made along the way
or that you could have done something
different in messaging or anything like
that
you know looking back i don't think so
i'm very proud of the work we did sure
you know any time i wish i would have
had more time to uh deal with the
woodward story but i can't help when cnn
drop something you know i'm someone who
uh the thing that i i
like least is when i don't have time to
prepare i had the thick binder obviously
so you know i'd spend hours and hours
and hours so when there was a new story
you know you know i'd regret not having
extra time to prepare but no i don't
think anything i said was a mistake i'm
very proud of what we did i'm very proud
of what president trump did how is it
for you being on the other side now i
mean now you're you're on a daily show
for an hour i go on every couple weeks
you get to fully share your opinions
that i assume you don't have to run by
anybody else and and you're obviously
pretty uncensored as is but just being
in now you're in the media you used to
be on the other side now you're in the
media how's that shift been for you
it's a lot of fun uh it is but you know
i guess being in this each and every day
in a different way uh you know i just
watched i sit beside harris faulkner and
i see what an amazing journalist she is
and you've been on with us on
outnumbered and how painstaking she is
and getting her details and her facts
right and i guess it's just um even a
little bit more frustrating to watch how
a good journalist operates and then to
have to report on how the bad journals
operate like uh cuomo if you can call
him that right no
you can't well you can use air quotes
then you can they're air quotes exactly
but you know i love it i mean being in
the private sector is a lot of fun i get
more time with my daughter i get to come
on outnumbered with you and podcasts
like this so it's it's a different uh
vibe for sure but a fun one
are you uh enjoying the collapse of cnn
the way the rest of us are i mean you
have to talk about it when i was on
outnumbered last week we talked about it
with all the cuomo nonsense um
it's kind of what they deserve
yeah what's weird is like i was at cnn
for
a year and a half about and it was
during the 2016 election so like i know
these guys pretty well every single
night i sat on the set with um you know
it was anderson cooper usually but i
would go on often to do don lemon i'd
wake up and do new day with chris cuomo
so it's weird because i knew these guys
um and yeah it's it's kind of
the um it's your comeuppance if you will
i mean i remember being on with chris
cuomo and a lot of people have forgotten
but we had a rather viral exchange where
he demanded that i call president trump
a liar like demanded it went on for like
20 minutes and then he ended by saying
you've lost all credibility with our
viewers i don't think we can ever have
you back because you won't call trump a
liar and it's just so ironic now to know
that he was lying to his viewers about
using his media contacts but yet he was
this like
this paragon of virtue
shouting down trump campaign personnel
uh because he was so noble and
forthright and honest and clearly that
was not the case yeah
what do you make of just sort of what's
happening broadly on the right right now
like it seems to be there's like it
seems very wide tent to me in some ways
and then there it also feels like well
as we get a little closer to the
midterms and then to 2024 depending on
what trump does it could all be
meaningless whatever we're seeing right
now
yeah look obviously 2022 is the most
important and that will determine i
think a lot of what happens in 2024
because it should be a total shellacking
of democrats next november and
republicans take back the house and
hopefully the senate as well but
assuming that plays out how most people
think it will play out um you know we'll
see if trump decides to throw his name
in the arena he's i think he's gonna be
a very difficult candidate to beat given
that he's got sky-high popularity in the
republican party an incredible track
record you had four successful years um
and you can just contrast that to the
one-year biden that's pretty clear but
we have the great thing we have the deep
bench in our party we have ron desantis
i mean he's the best like literally the
best and um tim scott's incredible i
mean the list goes on and on we've got
such a deep bench and you compare that
to biden
and vice president kamala harris who is
now you know like a madman attacking her
staff verbally and like vastly
incompetent so these two aren't it and
they're looking to pete buddha judge but
outside of this like handful of five
people who do they have they have no one
and we have a really deep edge so we'll
see the voters ultimately decide but
between trump desantis tim scott many
others pompeo a great binge
so i've been asking everybody this but
are you surprised how quickly this thing
got so bad i mean we're only 11 months
into this and supply chain shortages
obviously all the stuff with covid
mandates just you know gas prices
inflation the whole thing like across
the board i just don't know where you
could point to something and be like oh
no it is going well
i have to say i am rather shocked uh you
know for the first few months of the
biden administration they were trying to
put on this act of the adults are in the
room now rest easy breathe easy we have
brought back politeness
and friendship with our allies and we're
going to be praised by macron of being
back on the world stage and just they
had a lot of people fooled for about
four or five months and then afghanistan
happened and i said at the time this is
a turning point unmistakably this is a
turning point for this administration
and from afghanistan the polling started
to go south and then everything else
started to crumble bit by bit by bit to
the point where today i see the wall
street journal poll 41 approval 30 among
independents so i didn't think it would
get this bad this quick and in addition
to that have voters totally wake up and
say
wow we recognize how bad it is and for
those kind of numbers to be here
in december it just shows you it's not
just the pundits noticing people are
really feeling it at home if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about the media instead of
non-stop yelling check out our media
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out the full episode playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell